they come from somewhere over there
across the syrian-israeli border
here at the cf clinic the wounded
receives treatment and help
this young syrian is in intensive care
he has severe stomach and head wounds
which the doctors believe were probably
caused by an explosion he's 15 years old
they speak arabic to him but he barely
responds he doesn't even know he's in
israel
they are surprised you know for them
it's the enemy
they are not used to
they never thought and their dreams to
come here to israel to get treated
something very
very new for them
it's also a new situation for the
doctors they're very aware of the risk
to their patients and insist their faces
mustn't be shown on
camera the doctors know virtually
nothing about their patients apart from
a few exceptions
we got some letters
where in the pockets of those wounded
people if you can see with their blood
also
and the doctors there wrote down
what they did and sent us
the passion to continue to do our best
and we did we did
it's not clear exactly where the syrians
have come from and how they made it to
the border alive
once there they got picked up by the
israeli army and brought to the hospital
but the military is not willing to
comment on the situation
this young girl has also fled from syria
together with her mother
her leg was broken during a military
assault say doctors they hope she'll be
able to walk again in a few months
she wants to go home
but her future is uncertain
next week when i see a patient that i
treat him for one month two months every
day we talk every day so
you have some special feeling for them
and you know you don't know what is
their destiny you don't know what's
going to be with them
once they recover sufficiently the
patients are taken back to the border
and provided with medication for the
next few weeks
after that the doctors can only hope
that their help has not been in vain